after two days of violence baghdad's
heavily fortified green zone is empty of
protesters
[Music]
a sharp contrast to earlier scenes
violence broke out on monday when
powerful shayat leader mukhtar assad
announced he would quit politics
[Applause]
a day later he apologized and called on
his supporters to stand down and go home
there are some brutal militias but the
satirist shouldn't be vulgar i still
believe that my supporters are
disciplined that's why if you don't
withdraw from the parliament within 60
minutes i am not going to be the
soldiers movement leader again i don't
even want you to stage a peaceful
demonstration
[Applause]
it's not the first time sad supporters
have forced their way into the
presidential compound
they've been demonstrating for months
this is a political rivalry between
two different parties or sides of the
spectrum one side trying to maintain the
consensus agreement of the
consultational democracy impulse 2003
iraq and the other side which is the
soldiers movement trying to
revamp the political system in iraq
his party won most parliament seats in
elections in october but failed to form
a majority coalition
southern may have told his supporters to
stand down
but with such intense rivalry at the
heart of iraqi politics there are fears
that it's only a matter of time before
case and violence is repeated